I would like to see the boy as soon as
possible
keep him like this
it is best
mama won't buy books from me
and why is that
because I killed her
well my team was only months old the
Lord had spoken
we had to exercise Martin to get the
devil out I refused
and now they blame him for everything
bad that happens here they say martinus
evil
I came to help you understand Martine
has a condition if you just see right
here our new culture has a name for this
condition
do you believe you can cure him
[Applause]
it's just science
[Music]
a disease
are scared
and they need something to blame for
that fear and it's you
because you are different